you know we bring a lot of old friends
on the show we have them over we play
games
we smoke cigars we drink we drink and
smoke cigars while we play games but
sometimes we get the distinct privilege
of meeting somebody new and there is a
new voice out there she is taking
prageru by storm that would be amela
epinobi
amala is some i've only just met amela
right now i don't know
anything really about her other than
what i've seen online
so i'm going to grill her and figure out
who really
is amelia epinope i'm allah thank you
for being here thanks for having me
michael i'm ready to get grilled are you
ready
just get ready for the hot seat okay
the producers have put together a list
of questions that are supposed to tell
us
everything that we need to know about
you okay i'm ready
first question would you rather
smoke a cigar with dennis prager or
drink a beer with will wit
oh this you're starting right out the
gate with very very easy questions here
michael that's easy
yes how's that easy because i love
dennis more than anything
so i'm gonna go smoking the cigar with
dennis prager
you know the other great thing about
smoking a cigar with dennis is dennis
doesn't
like cubans but people give him cubans
so when you go and smoke a cigar with
him he'll have these gorgeous
i mean like hundred dollar cigars that
he just he's going to throw them in the
trash so you get to pick
the scraps from dennis's table are
really really wonderful so every cuban
that you give to dennis prager goes to
michael moore
goes straight to me all of them should
and
a fair number of them have next up
would you rather debate candace owens
or ben shapiro oh no okay now we have a
harder question
let's see i'm gonna go
honestly there's no there's no right
answer to this i think i would i may
fail either way but i'm gonna go with
candace owens
you would rather debate candace yeah i'd
like to i'd like to feel like
i'm crazy yes this hearing in my opinion
is a farce
yes look they're both obviously both
very intelligent very very
serious sharp people however
while ben is just a fact machine right
it would be
definitely a formidable experience right
candace
is a force of nature yeah she is like a
military-grade
cannon and i don't i never want that
thing aimed in my direction
she'll bring the claws out on me yes
maybe you're maybe you're uh
more courageous than i am um next
question
next question since there is a good
chance that this
actually may happen would you prefer to
be banned from
youtube or tick tock ooh
well considering you've already been
banned off of tick tock probably
three or four times now have you are you
back on at the moment
or i'm back on at the moment but prageru
is is permanently
banned off of tick tock so i think i'll
take another round with tick-tock i'm so
used to it right now
yeah that's fair i would like to be
banned off of tick-tock
because it's much more conducive to
virtue right you know i only tried
tick-tock
truly my wife and i sat next to each
other we tried it for about 20 minutes
and it's like crack for your brain i
thought instagram was bad but you're
just
first of all some of the stuff is uh you
know not fit for the queen but then
you're
scrolling through it and you it's all
video so you just can't look away it's
so immersive
it is the most atrocious piece of social
media that i think has ever been created
so i don't mind being banned on it and
where can where can people find you on
tick tock
people can find me at omalephanobe on
tick tock uh if it stays there i mean
right after i say this i could be gone
that's true you could be
uh okay speaking of debates
this actually does get a little bit more
toward political philosophy okay
sure would you rather
have a debate with a blm leader
on racial justice or
with a dsa member say on
socialism
both of them would be i think very very
easy i think i could hit both of those
out of the park
i'm gonna go blm activists because i
used to be
one so i think i can meet them head to
head have you seen that interview with
uh larry elder and dave rubin where
larry elder looks some dead in the face
and he goes give me an example
of systemic racism and dave just can't
do it that's who i would be
it's brutal because yeah i mean in that
sort of a circumstance if you've got a
lot going in i mean you were you were a
i know you were a leftist activist but
you're saying you were kind of like more
blm i was definitely associated with blm
so i did
virtually every single leftist campaign
that you can think of out in florida i
was a part of so blm was one of those
wow wow because i agree with you i mean
i think
socialism is evil it's been it's it's
the second oldest faith of mankind is
communism that's what whitaker chambers
told us
goes back to the garden of eden when the
serpent said ye shall be his gods
many popes have written about how just
evil and rotten and terrible socialism
is
i know now people seem to think that
jesus was a socialist or something but
it's just preposterous to say that um
you know i think it was john xxiii who
said no christian can subscribe even to
moderate socialism so it's like i get it
it's really evil
but i also think it's kind of beating a
dead horse at this point to talk about
socialism
that's not the big issue people aren't
out in the streets for
you know socialist summer burning down
cities blm is burning down right cities
right and the whole crt thing in schools
i mean it
just keeps going race race race so
that's where i would that's where i
would fight the battle
yeah i think you're right i think no no
one's really teaching
marks in schools or any of the sort of
or lenin or or engels or trotsky but
people are they're studying kimberly
crenshaw right they're studying all the
all these really
radical racialized marxists
yeah yeah exactly so it is it is marxism
in a way so maybe socialism is the
battle but it's like
but it's in this cultural front this is
actually the subject of my upcoming book
speechless by the way controlling words
controlling minds which is available
for order right now for actual order
just a little brief plug in there thank
you
for setting me up it was just so smooth
it was thank you i
okay i think you're right i totally
agree with you on that point uh
would you rather have joe biden finish
out his term as president
or have kamala harris take office before
oh goodness it's that's a tough one too
i can't even
wait for joe biden to finish a sentence
at this point yeah none of us can
i'm thinking i've got to go with the
lesser of two evils i think
kamala is a very very dark horse in in
the running here i'm gonna go with joe
biden let him finish the term hopefully
he makes it
yeah i i agree she's so grating it's not
it's obviously the whole thing is just
being controlled by the liberal
establishment
both of those people are empty suits
right but between joe biden's
simpering and daughtering inanity and
kamala harris's witchy
cackle i would rather
grit my teeth and bear the biden
mumbling that's from
it is she's oh gosh oh she's what a
woman what a woman
what a woman speaking of these sorts of
left-wing women
would you rather be stuck in an elevator
with
aoc or nancy pelosi ooh
okay i'm gonna go
with nancy pelosi at least she's got a
little bit of a mature aura to her
aoc i think once i got out of the
elevator she would accuse me of
attacking her or something so
i gotta gotta keep my wits about me and
i don't want a lawsuit on my hand so i'm
gonna go with nancy pelosi
i agree i i think actually you could
have a conversation with pelosi
right whereas with aoc she's just
always making these really disingenuous
bad
faith everything's on social media yeah
and pelosi also
when she kind of loses her marbles every
so often she goes into that really
pleasant do you remember she was on a
morning show she said
good morning sunday morning good morning
sunday morning it's just a there's an
answer to a question no one asked oh the
abracadabra thing that she did you
remember that
yes yeah she's a strange at least it
would be just a strange interesting
experience with her
yes i agree okay so we're like totally
simpatico
yeah we're great okay okay i have to ask
this question
okay yeah i remember when i was in
college you would hear this all the time
you'd hear
hey you know i'm a conservative but i'm
i'm a fiscal conservative
social liberal i always thought it was
always the way to say like hey i'm a
conservative
but i still want to get invited to
parties so hey i'm a conservative but i
still want girls to talk to me right
so would you say the kind there are so
many different types of conservatives
the libertarians the neo-conservatives
the traditional conservatives
the populists and this that and the
other thing right but 100 conservatives
in a room
you get 100 different answers right
are you socially
liberal socially moderate even let's say
socially libertarian get off my lawn
or are you one of those dread
evil social conservatives i am a social
conservative my
girl all right i love it yeah no i don't
i don't feel like
i need to whisper that at all i'm a
social conservative all the way right
because i
sometimes you'll hear this you'll hear
people say look you know i'm
i'm conservative in this way but i
actually don't think the government
should have anything to say about any
any cultural issue whatsoever and i like
let's just cut taxes and that's it and i
think
the gop has been just cutting taxes for
30 years what has it gotten us
right the country's in rubble the real
problem in our country right now
is is a cultural problem especially when
it comes to young people so that's why
i'm here that's why i'm at prageru
that's why i'm fighting the fight
because that's what happened to me i was
a young person i was indoctrinated by
the left
i met a conservative who was out there
trying to talk to young people
and i found all these conservative
videos videos like yours and that's what
woke me up so if i can do that for some
crazy young people
that's what i'll do now i love you
saying this because
so often i think boomers believe
that young conservatives believe
that we shouldn't hear anything about
society or culture
right basically when when i hear
sometimes i'll go to
conservative fundraisers or things like
that i'll hear you know the way to reach
the youths
is to stop talking about abortion or
marriage or family or society or
any of these and i think you've never
talked to a teenager or a 20-something
in your life because
every young person who's a young
conservative that i know
is significantly more socially
conservative
than even the millennials but certainly
gen x or the boomers
right the hill that i die on uh in terms
of conservatism is definitely not a
fiscal one it's a social one because the
culture is really the problem and when
you meet young people whether they're on
the left or the right what they're
talking about is social issues
yeah that's the real the real war here
100 percent this is
amelo this is good this is christian
thank you so
oh and this is a really tough one okay
okay i'll tell you what i'm going to
start with the less tough one then i'm
going to bring you to the really tough
sure okay i'm ready so joe biden
he's not looking good he's looking a
little slow no he is
if he does not run for re-election in
2024
who would you rather see
be the democrat nominee now i know
kamala is kind of the anointed one
but assuming you can get any democrat
you want who would you rather see
i want to see i think i would want to
see the craziest of the crazy
just because it's got to get so
ridiculous that that nobody can
can possibly vote for them maybe like uh
an aoc or an ilhan
just to show them the true craziness of
the left and anybody who's on the right
that goes up against that i think will
win
in a landslide that's you know it's a
dangerous game it is
the game the game of a young person it
is gamble it all
red 23. you got to see a crazy one
michael
all in yeah aoc i think will just
be old enough in 2024 should be exactly
35
right lady never tells but yeah i think
that's true okay so you're in you're in
for aoc fair enough
fair argument now the really tough
question
ron desantis is doing great stuff in
florida he is he's doing he's a very
good governor yep
he he appears to want to run for
president right he's kind of taking on
some trump-like
attributes sure in the demeanor in
the speech and he's i think he's running
for the trump lane
of the republican presidential primary
so let's say that desantis wants to run
and trump wants to run who do you want
to run oh
i think i'm gonna put my name in the hat
for the young buck i think i'm gonna go
for desantis
okay he's the governor that i've seen
obviously i'm from florida i moved from
florida to l.a for preger hugh but
he's really been running game in florida
he's been actually making changes look
what he's done with big tech look what
he's done with the lockdowns
look what he's done just all over the
state he's actually making changes
so i i would love to see somebody young
fresh and conservative hop in the ring
fair enough and you know one hopes that
if both those guys want to run
i hope they they work it out and you
know the worst thing i think
because part of me thinks man i'd love
to see trump run again part of me thinks
there are a lot of i mean forget even
just desantis there are a lot of really
good candidates
on the republican side i just don't want
them to kill each other
exactly you know that would be that
would be unfortunate don't go don't go
dutch on it just
just pick one and let them run yes
that's right
would you if you
okay two questions i'm gonna start off
with one okay do you think that the
universities can be
reformed or do you think they need to be
basically demolished
okay this is this is a very very tough
one
you're a tenured influencer at prager
university you have institutional
backing
i've been there a whole of three months
so i'm very far back to this one
uh let's see i think
i don't know i think we need to reform
the education system although i think
it's going to be very very difficult
so it might need uh some destruction
here i don't see the use in really
attending a college or university unless
you absolutely have to at this point
which is leaning me towards it just
needs to be destroyed
yeah yeah i tell you you know i'm i'm
always a great defender
of reforming things over the knocking
them down and i'm a great defender of
the universities
right and yet even the late roger
scrutin one of the great conservative
philosophers of the last few decades
he said in his very posh british ways i
think they basically have to be
destroyed
i think they must it becomes very very
difficult if the thing is
totally rotted out from the core i mean
i could name
fewer than half a dozen universities in
america or colleges
where you could still get a good
education really that's not not infected
by this stuff so okay fair enough
today well actually okay i want to ask
you this one too
okay if you could only abolish one of
these institutions
you've got your gavel you will abolish
it gotcha
would you abolish the universities or
would you abolish social media
okay i'm going to
pull out the gavel and i'm going to say
boom social media i think not everybody
attends a university but every single
person is on social media
and they're truly controlled by these
super far left big tech overlords so if
i'm going to choose one
i think i'm going to choose the one with
the most impact and that would be social
media but the problem look i'm with you
i understand this
however however you're on social media i
am on social media we know about you
because of so
we know about me because of social media
that is true you make a fair point
so now are we if we get rid of the
social media then it's what then it's
just
nbc again so that's no good but if we
empower the social media then it's jack
dorsey
hipster rasputin that's no good do i get
to change my gavel michael
you maybe i but it you're in a you're in
between a rock and a hard place i am in
between a rock and a hard place they
both have significant influence on our
society
yes where we are churning out radicals
on both sides you can knock you can
abolish them both
that's fine
conservatives know there are limits to
things all right we'll put a pin in that
one okay
today would it be better for black
americans to abolish
affirmative action or to expand
affirmative action abolish 100 percent
there's no i want to ask you this on
your answer because i
i mean i think the affirmative action
stuff is terrible and i really don't
like it
however i am
open to the idea that history has an
effect
on current society and history you know
we're conservatives we believe in the
past and the future and
the way that one generation affects
another right
so when people talk about the legacy of
slavery i think it's over wrought i
think it's
kind of silly i think there are a lot of
other factors however there is
i think something to it there is
something to
you know the sins of the father coming
onto the sun and all these
so you'd get rid of affirmative action
is there
is there any argument for it anymore i
not that i can see now
and i think my my come back to that is
is there any right privilege
uh thing that i have as a as a black
person that you have
is there any right or privilege that you
have that i don't and i don't think
that's true anymore i don't think i'm
held back by
the current society of today and while
there may be
small remnants of you know the past of
the transgressions of america i don't
think they're as significant as the left
tells us they are
yeah and if you achieve something
through affirmative action
how much should you actually achieve i
think it's stripping people of of true
accomplishment of true success if you
got it because of your race
yeah no i think that's true i remember
clarence thomas wrote about this in his
memoir
he couldn't get it he went to yale law
school this guy's one of the smartest
lawyers in the country
and he he couldn't get a job because
they all thought he was an affirmative
action case
right and he said then i learned the
value of a yale degree in
this affirmative action society sure it
wasn't bupkus it was worth nothing
exactly um yeah no that's a good point
and it's it's also just
everyone suffers everyone does and
everyone's got some privileges and
everyone suffers
and it's just not conducive to
flourishing
to whine and complain and try to ask for
special entitlements
right because of suffering it just won't
it won't make you strong
it won't you know you won't thrive okay
last question
last question if you could give one
piece of advice to your younger self
now you are a lady never tells her age
you're fairly young at the moment so i
don't know your younger self would be
even younger
sure but you went through this leftist
period this
blm period what would you tell yourself
i would tell myself and i answered this
question earlier i would tell myself
that you are nobody's victim
and the people who are trying to
convince you that you are a victim are
the ones that are truly out to get you
in are truly against you
and you you won't get anywhere if you
listen to those people and i listened to
them for a very very long time
and then i found somebody who told me no
you are not and you can be successful
and you are successful
and that completely changed my mindset
it changed my worldview and now here i
am
so i think i'm a testament to don't let
anybody tell you you're a victim
yeah i think that's terrific and you
you've
had many difficulties in your life okay
and we don't need to get into all i want
to talk about the most specific one
the silent k people i know i can
really identify with this people i'm
sure they pronounce it
yes they do michael michael canoles they
think it was
an anglicization of cannoli at ellis
island
it wasn't it's not we both share the
same struggle you know and we're we're
different races we're different genders
we share the same struggle that's silent
k
you're assuming you're assuming a lot of
things about my sex and my race but
that's for another episode
amela epinobi thank you for being here
where can people find you
they can find me anywhere on social
media and if you guys want to follow
prageru that's where i'm making content
so you can find me anywhere i'm all over
the place
all over the place and you can find
amela on tik tok for now you cannot find
me on tick tock okay
nobody wants me on tick tock amla thank
you so much for being here thank you for
having me and i do want you on tick tock
[Music]
asap
[Music]
you